-It is time to play a game of
deception called
"True Confessions."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
My opponents tonight
are co-hosting
"Miley's New Year's Eve Party,"
which starts on
New Year's Eve at 10:30 p.m.,
right here on NBC and Peacock.
Please welcome Miley Cyrus
and Pete Davidson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Came out hot.
-What up?
-Wow! Great to see you.
Nice to see you.
That's -- Come on!
-How are you?
-Looking fantastic.
-We came in hot.
-You really came in hot.
Now, guys,
here's how this works.
In front of us each
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true. The other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then they have to come to
a unanimous decision --
is it the truth or is it a lie?
Miley, you will go first.
Audience, which envelope
should she open?
1 or 2?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Always.
-Always 1?
-Number 1. Let's go.
-Let's start taking notes.
-Alright.
-[ Clears throat ]
♪♪
-If this is a lie, I --
-I recently have met
Flavor Flav.
-Oh, yeah, okay.
-This is very believable.
-Okay.
This is very interesting, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I, too, have met Flavor Flav.
Where was it?
-Where was it?
It was at a radio-show event.
So in front of a lot of people.
-Introduced you onstage?
-And he was like "Gwen Stefani!"
-He went "Gwen..." for like --
It's still happening somewhere
in another universe.
It's still happening.
-I think that's true.
-And did you come out?
Did you say like,
"Hey, everybody,
I'm not Gwen Stefani"?
-Well, I was very excited to
debut what I thought was
a new and original look with my
red lipstick and blonde hair.
And it was kind of
disappointing,
'cause I love Flavor Flav.
-And you were also dating
Blake Shelton at the time.
-Yes.
-So that's very confusing.
-Yeah, it was very confusing.
-I think this is funny
and I think it's a true story.
-I think it's super-true.
-I think it's true.
-When do I say?
-Yes, now.
-It's true.
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, buddy.
-There we go.
-That's very true.
-Yeah.
-Are you kidding me?
-No.
-So, you're debuting a new look,
and you're like, "Here we come."
-But it was really good.
You know, I was with my dad,
and he said like,
"Who is Gwen Stefani?"
And that made me feel better.
-Okay, good, good. Yeah.
-But my dad
lives on another planet
and hasn't left the farm
since 1992, but...
-That's not bad. I love that.
Okay, here we go.
It's my turn.
Which envelope
should I open, guys?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Why is it 2 for me
and 1 for you?
-I like it.
-2, okay. 2.
"The last time I had
a Big Mac was in 2006
with Tobey Maguire after
an Arctic Monkeys concert.
♪♪
-I feel you.
-There's no way you're not
having Big Macs, dude.
You're too --
-Do I look like --
-You're Cool Boy Fallon, man.
There's no way you're not out
at 2:00 in the morning
getting a nice Big Mac.
-What's your favorite
Arctic Monkeys song?
-To be honest,
I can't remember one song.
-See? It's a lie.
-It's not true.
-It's not true. Yeah.
-No, I saw the whole concert.
I just don't remember
any song from --
-No way.
-Nope.
No.
-No way, dude.
No way.
-That's not true.
You are so bad at this.
-You name me --
-You are so --
-You name me an
Arctic Monkeys song.
-I don't even know
what the [bleep] they are.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what I'm saying.
But I went. I did.
I went to a concert with
Tobey Maguire
after our late-night show.
-Tobey Maguire in 2006 --
very believable.
-He kept saying,
"It's my cheat night."
-Yeah?
-I still --
-No way. No way, dude.
We're having Big Macs
right after this.
-Uh-huh.
You smell like
Big Macs right now.
-Yeah.
It's the Irish.
-That is a lie, yeah.
You guys, I mean,
that is a total lie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I've never seen them
in concert, also,
but I don't like Big Macs,
by the way.
I'm more of a
Quarter Pounder type of dude.
-Are they like a Blue Man Group?
-No. They're a famous band.
-Oh.
-But I had a whole fake lie --
Whatever. You guys got me.
Alright, here we go.
Pete, it's your turn.
-Alright, guys.
-What do you think?
2 or number 1?
-1?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-You guys got 1. I got 2.
-This is very specific.
-"There's no way
you're not throwing
Big Macs down at 2:00 a.m."?
-Come on, Jimmy and the boys?
Jimmy gets down with the boys.
-I got to go have a Big Mac.
-A lot of you guys
don't know about Jimmy.
Jimmy's a little boy.
-Hey!
-Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-I don't even know if --
Alright.
I should read the e-mails
that they send out.
-Yeah, sorry.
Yeah, before the show?
Yeah, sorry about that. Yeah.
-Okay. "I got caught by the cops
while smoking my first joint."
♪♪
-It almost seems too obvious.
-It seems really obvious.
-Yeah.
But you got caught by the cops
the first time
you ever smoked a joint?
-Yeah, the first time I
ever smoked a joint, it was --
We skipped school.
We went to the train station,
and, for some reason,
we thought smoking in a
train station was very discreet.
-This already sounds like
a stereotyp--
This is, like --
-Yeah, it sounds like
a scene from
"The Outsiders" or something.
-I think he does.
-Yeah.
-So, this is in Staten Island?
-This is in Staten Island.
Staten Island!
Staten Isle! Whoa!
-Oh!
-And, so you --
-The cop was like,
"Oh, is that a joint?"
-"You got to
smoke it like that."
-Oh!
-Alright, so, did you know
you were going to smoke pot?
-We made a plan.
I skipped math class,
because I was like,
"I'm never going
to figure it out, ever.
Why...
You know, might as well get into
this thing for the next --
I guess rest of my life."
And I went with
this guy I met, Mike.
And we went out to
the train station.
We rolled up a blunt at
the train station
and smoked it there.
-Don't they always say
that, like,
a lie just has
way too many details?
Like, this seems too detailed.
There's no way you remember --
You smoke a lot of weed.
You don't remember this story
in this much detail
if it really happened.
-Yeah, right? Mike.
His name was --
This guy named Mike.
-Yeah, Mike.
I would say his last name,
but I don't know what
he's doing right now.
-Do you even remember
the flight here yesterday?
-Yeah, exactly.
-Unh-unh.
-Wait. I don't know.
Did you eat a Big Mac after?
-With the boys.
Of course. Yeah, of course.
Always with the boys.
-I vote lie.
-I'll go with Miley's gut.
I'm going to say --
But, also -- Wait.
Pete's luck.
Pete Davidson's luck.
-Pete don't miss.
-That we know.
-The reason that
he's a comedian is 'cause
things like this happen
to him in real life.
-Just the details seemed like
you were trying to oversell it.
-Okay. I agree.
I'm with Miley.
It didn't happen.
[ Drumroll ]
-It is true.
-What?!
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪
-Yeah. And...
So, this is what --
This is -- By the way,
kids at home,
this is how you get out of
when you busted with drugs.
This is how you get out of it.
So...
[ Laughter ]
No, it's important. Yeah.
For your kids, as well. So...
"When Uncle Pete
comes to party."
-"Uncle Pete!"
-Oh!
So, we went to
the train station.
We walked back up.
And these
two cops follow us, right?
So, I obviously know
they're cops,
because I grew up in, like, a
blue-collar fireman/cop --
Everybody -- you know what
they look like.
-Yeah.
-So, my boy goes, "Oh, no!"
And he just starts
running, right?
So they go, obviously, and
tackle him and put him in cuffs,
and I just stand there.
And they're like,
"Go against the car."
And I'm like,
"You know what, guys?
You know, you did your job.
I got --"
-How old are you?
-I'm like 16.
I was like, "You know,
I got busted with weed."
You know, I'm not going to try
and run from this, you know?
This is -- I skipped school.
I was a bad boy today."
And they wrote down
all my information.
They wrote down
my buddy's information.
And they were like, "Alright.
You can go back to class
because you're a stand-up guy.
As for your friend?
Right to the slammer."
-Wow! That is a lesson to be
learned right there.
A lesson to be
learned out there.
-Always succumb.
-My thanks to Miley Cyrus,
Pete Davidson.
We're talking to Miley and Pete
more after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪